I'm sure that we can all be United in
saving people from the cages of Russian
prisons unfortunately and there are some
in the world and here among you who turn
a blind eye to those cages and illegal
annexations and I'm here so that
everyone can take an honest look no
matter how hard the Russians try to
influence
there must still be Independence and I
want to thank Saudi Arabia I want to
thank the majority of you for supporting
Forum International positions and the
U.N Charter dear participants your
people have already seen that ukrainians
are people of Peace of real peers
and I'm also sure all your Nations will
understand the main call I want to live
here in jira a noble call to all of you
to help protect our people including
Ukrainian Muslim Community
with me here
in their honorable Mustafa jamiliv the
leader of the Crimean Tatar people one
of the indigenous peoples of Ukraine
whose home is Crimea the center of
Muslim culture in Ukraine
for centuries the Crimea Tatar have been
and should remain an integral and strong
part of the Muslim Community of the
world but Premiere was the first to
suffer from the Russian occupation and
until now most of those who are
subjected to repression
in the occupied Crimea are Muslims we
already have a positive experience with
Saudi Arabia regarding
the release of our people captured by
Russia we can expand this experience and
even
if there are people here at the summit
who have a different view on the war on
our land calling it a conflict I'm sure
that we can all be United in saving
people from the cages of Russian prisons
unfortunately and there are some in the
world and here among you who turn a
blind eye to those cages and illegal
annexations and I'm here so that
everyone can take an honest look no
matter how hard the Russians try to
influence
there must still be Independence and I
want to thank Saudi Arabian I want to
thank the majority of you for supporting
Forum International positions and the
U.N Charter